I would only have protected sex what do
you mean she her goal is to get pregnant
so you just keep wearing a cond first
off I don't friends I only
[Music]
fans all right take a look at this
photo and uh something what you think oh
dude it's cool huh cool pck why does he
look like Marlon Waynes kind of you
think he looks like Marlin way the thing
yeah that's the news a guy looks like
Marlon Wayne Marlon Wayne's look alike
does he have five babies mamas oh yeah
they're pregnant wa dude that's where
your brain went mine went to this is the
first ever pregnant orgy cuz everyone's
going like that all that they're holding
their babies this is our baby daddy wow
Bart see so he's Mormon what's the big
deal he's not Mormon that's why it's a
big deal so this guy that's wild that
they're all down if the chicks are all
down Z will he's uh throwing he's thrown
a baby shower for all five of the women
that he got pregnant pretty much the
same he came in them all in the same
month he got good C wow he's very potent
gu potent he got that good good high te
maybe that's a new compliment hey man
you got some good C on you huh how did
he find five chicks that are all like
all good with it you've got some
reliable do you think it's okay here's
the question do you think it's harder to
find five chicks who would be cool with
this or one guy who would be cool with
this
oh dude well it just depends does a guy
have funds yeah I don't think they even
care about that [__] he's a Tik tocker
and he has rap songs are they good dude
they're very I think if you look in the
lower IQ of areas you could find chicks
that are down M cuz you'll be like yo
check this out you don't ever have to
work you just have my kid I'll take care
of you whether it's real or not but if
you spit good enough game oh yeah it's
coming my [__] that's game I don't like
that you said that right next to me you
know arguably there are uh lower IQ
zones and higher population densities so
you dude might not be hard the thing is
you don't need money once you're you
have a kid and you're single the
government takes care of you and then
you get a check for every kid that you
got I think he might have agreed to pay
child support for them yeah but that's
still not enough they could they're not
technically married and everything's
verbal you know like you could talk a
good game but the follow through is
where it matters yeah I feel like this
is just a a tough situation like long
game wise I feel like this is hard so
listen to this quote from one of them
and tell me if your suspicions of low IQ
are actually you better not have four
syllable words coming out of these
chicks yeah they all said Cornucopia
eight times so she goes we can't change
the fact that he's our baby daddy and
everything happens for a reason we've
decided to work together and our
families are supportive of our decision
we've accepted each other it's better
for the little
ones yeah I is really
high but the same time they're you know
what that's kind of smart actually
they're just accepting like he cheated
on all of us even if it didn't happen
that way it's more like we got to
[__] make the best of it we could be
trifling [__] fighting over this [__]
and making each other like you know have
a hard time or we can boun like work
together as Sister Wives yeah that's
just Mormon to me who here believes that
it could just be a publicity stunt for
cloud CL industry plan rap yeah if he's
a rap Tik tocker and he just [__]
gets like five pregnant people to be
yeah that's very oh it's like a
prosthetic they're wearing like they're
not even or they're just random pregnant
ladies that they just found and he just
hired them that honestly sounds way more
reasonable cuz it does say here that
like if this is just a big Ploy then all
of them are participating pretty well
because like their big things is that
there's no drama between them which
might be the most unbelievable yeah no
[__] way dude no [__] way yeah I
don't believe that that's a TV show
waiting to happen too show how many
women five five yeah what if all the
babies come out and they all look
different they all look complet like
completely different like there's no
similarity like half of them are Asian
yeah like the chicks also cheated on
them and they're actually other so
there's more to this family now there's
like four dads then you just have more
seasons of that show yeah that's true
that's true would you in any point in
time of your life whether it's later now
before agree to let's say you have like
a really beautiful friend who's like hey
I don't want a relationship I just want
a baby can you please make me pregnant
you don't have to pay child
support and and then it gets notorized
um if I didn't have a girlfriend yeah
let's say you maybe and there was like a
contract that I don't owe anything yeah
really yeah I would only have protected
sex what do you mean she her goal is to
get pregnant so you just keep wearing a
condom he he sneaks it on I don't know
what's going on it ain't
happening you you wouldn't go with that
deal if a if a girl friend of yours was
like hey I really need a kid I don't
want to go to the first off I don't [__]
friends I only [__]
fans second of all great line that's an
amazing one man I hope your bumper big
enough for
that the reason why Empire's fall is
because you have well it's hard enough
to have one Queen and then you have a
couple of male heirs that fight over the
throne and then what happens they start
stabbing each other up and [__] and then
they divide within the family yeah it's
even worse when you have hella
concubines and now you have five sons
from different [__] women and they
all want a piece of the Empire it's even
harder yeah oh so I have Joe's got an
Empire 2500 $ to my name that's maybe
four zeros if you have a
decimal after 25 but like if you if you
want to divide up all of my
wealth if you add everything that I got
I'm not willing to cause that kind of
drama for my family like I'm setting
them up for failure right cuz people
will kill each other for 500 bucks in
his world oh 1,000% you know how much
that [__] is in [__] that's more
percentage than dollars right there he's
like I got one ethereum that's a great
that's a great stat there's a th% chance
someone will kill you for 500 bucks
that's a great huge it's a huge but it's
500 bucks with a decimal two extra zero
okay they're going to fight for the
inheritance the Empire and the power so
let's say let's say that you did it
right and and this friend of yours gets
pregnant with your child they do end up
minding their own business you're not
bothered at all what are some of the
downsides to this in the long run if oh
wait maybe I wouldn't do it cuz then the
kid wouldn't grow up without a dad yeah
or he would grow up with a stepdad and
then he would turn into like the
autistic
kid don't care who you point to for that
at me I was oh [__] I grew up in a
broken home like damn dude and I had a
lot of trouble up until like I was 18
you what you had a lot of trouble
because that's cuz I grew up in a broken
home oh so I had a lot of trouble other
until I was like 18 or 19 yeah but look
at all the successful people people that
use trouble to become successful if it's
strategically and intentionally a broken
home oh yeah that could be a thing that
might be loving actually it's more like
a home pre-assembly isn't that weird
like you don't see your dad but at night
you hear your dad [__] your mom
you're like did Dad come back home again
and then you're like you open the door
is Dad here your mom's like no I've been
sleeping alone all night like you sleep
alone
weird oh what's the situation saying cuz
that's what you're saying you're saying
it's a fake broken home right so in the
daytime where's Daddy I don't know but
at night just [__] all night long
like How's Mama [__] my dad fake
broken home sounds sick is that because
she's dating me is that no it's [__]
dad so it's cuz a fake broken home oh
duh Ryan at home now I get it it's like
broken home simulator yeah at night
there's still really great software
busting it down still busting it down
yeah yeah I always felt like cuz I to be
honest I did have uh an ex that I had
broken up with and then she was like she
wanted your c yeah because you cuz she
wanted an Asian baby but did you but did
you say oh yeah you're Indian that's
Asian but did you say like that's but
did you
say did you say can I can I just give
you my [__] and you go get a turkey
baster or did you say I [__] that [__]
for you dude out of the two things I can
provide the turkey baser is way easier
couldn't I just do a two for
imagine I'm like I'll give you the come
you got to go fight a Rous cuz you got
to still come into the baster yeah like
I just come into you the reason I didn't
wasn't so it was because I thought about
the long run how do you explain that
your kid's going to come looking for you
someday oh yeah you know what I mean
even if she finds a guy right after me
and they just like you know I I do think
that there is a difference between like
for example in vitro children that like
you know like a a mom who always wanted
to have a child but doesn't have a life
partner and then goes and gets you know
goes to the catalog inseminates herself
artificially and then creates a child I
do think that there's a difference
between potentially I don't know I'm not
an adopted child or a manufactured child
like that if you will that's going to be
like where's my father who my mom had a
relationship with you know what I mean
yeah that would happen yeah yeah so I
think in a similar sense hypothetically
if you were the turkey baster as Joe so
eloquently put it you know donate your
sperm to a person in need it's not the
same as like where's my father mother
yeah I think there's still might though
I I know I I think there's a little bit
I just think it's slightly different
versus like if they were truly like
together oh I see what created the child
and the father bounced yeah yeah right
yeah true I see what you I feel like it
might only be like 2% off cuz I feel
like when you're growing up you see all
your homies have par like you know Mommy
and Daddy Mommy and Daddy Mommy and
Daddy but like imagine explaining to the
kid as they're maturing and be like oh
like where's my like how was I created
then it's like I went to like a sperm
donor yeah is there you might not be
like I need to find my father there's
people that still do 20m me that she
could have still I think she honestly
like if we did do this she probably
would have still had a partner the thing
was that she felt like she was getting
older and she's like I want to have a
baby before she reaches you know yeah I
get that do you guys do you guys have um
kind of Chinese emperor Tendencies or
like genas KH and uh uh you know
Tendencies where you want to have a
thous spread your seed yeah like there's
a part of that but then there's also the
other part of that where you're like
that's a lot of responsibility yeah I
think in society today yeah that's all
resp to be fair gas Khan I don't think
he took care of all his children yeah
but then I think for us we have that
other side of culture where like we
we're all raised to think like guys
should be very involved yeah right like
genas Khan I think that era was like oh
I want her go get her do you find
yourself feeling a little gangy
sometimes yeah a little gangy so the
iMed OT animal in me goes [__] as many
girls as you come and [__] cream pie
[__] and I think that's a
natural man thing secondary animal also
does and then the second thing is dude
can you imagine a room full of a
thousand babies like that's [__] dope
that's like having like you're on the
ground on the floor and thousands of
puppies come up and lick your face
that's a fun time that's a fun time
right so you're just like holding a baby
here holding a baby there and it's like
cuteness everywhere
that's cool and you're like I did this
these guys are my homies like all of
them but I'm smart enough to know all of
their [__] moms hate each other all
of these [__] are going to be
in their kids ears and be like one day
you'll be king no one day you'll be king
and then they grow up and then they're
like [__] you I don't like you I love my
mom cuz she spent all this time you're
out there doing War [__] you were never
home yeah they each have the model
you're out there beheading people taking
over Villages the story is I think the
The Arc of the story is very true to
present day you just take out the the
you were out there all my sons are going
to want want my attention right so all
of them are just going to be like I'm
the biggest Warrior look at me dad I
killed my brother like but didn't you
just say you're you're in the culture
though of also being like instead of
just like oh like I want that concubine
or where you're also like oh but you
want to be present in your kids what are
you also doing beheading
people because I'm still gang is Khan Oh
I thought you were just Gish yeah no no
but G it's kind of like if I was in his
I would have the conscience of Joe and
the education of Joe but the power of
gang is there's only 365 days in the
year and there's a thousand children how
the [__] am I going to spend time with
all of them yeah true you can't three
per day
duh but then they're going to fight for
attention see it's not it's never like
enough dude having five kids with five
different baby mamas at the same time is
just incredible it can't there's no way
that you think not as soon as you said
it's a publicity stunt I'm like it feels
like it might be it probably is Right
feels like a very rap Centric type thing
to do unless you're Floyd Mayweather but
even Floyd Mayweather didn't even do
that and this guy is like on social
media like he has a very he's like 2.5
mil followers it's almost like of course
you know you know when you're with one
chick and they can't figure out what to
eat is it more chicks they can help each
other figure it out or is it get even
worse gets even worse damn cuz think
about all these ladies they all have
different personalities different tastes
like how are they going to raise the
kids they can't even figure [__] out
it's even more confused hey if you don't
figure it out when I'm back in 5 minutes
you have to pay for dinner and then it's
easy D who hold on that's a real hack
did you think of that yourself when you
have five baby mamas yeah it's in the
rule books even if you have one
girlfriend you're supposed to be our
bread winner I saw I saw a hack recently
that I actually used and it was really
really helpful it's like when you see
your wife you're just like guess where
I'm taking you to dinner and then she
actually guess like I'm I'm like no
really guess and then she'll be like
shaboo and I'll be like AB so [__]
yeah
got the reservation sweetheart let's go
that [__] actually works 30 second combo
I don't know if that'll you just has to
do it five times yeah it's all different
answers so probably like tell me
[__] what is I ain't guessing
I'm like
[__] God you D that's that's how this
goes these things don't work on you you
[__] B you know why you know why we
never had that problem before is cuz
girls
[Music]
cooked